[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
bettina zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein es gab mal eine zeit
da war es selbst hollywood irgendwie zu
doof als internationale bösewichte immer
die russen auftreten zu lassen mit
pelzmütze und eisigem blick da kämpfte
dann auch james bond nicht mehr gegen
kgb-agenten da schien der kalte krieg
vorbei auch im kino erledigt nicht mehr
aktuell diese zeit ist gar nicht so
lange her und sie wird so schnell nicht
wiederkommen die nato hat sich auf ihrem
gipfel in madrid eine neue strategie
gegeben sie stellt sich auf nichts
weniger ein als einen konflikt der
systeme russland wird vom strategischen
partner zur bedrohung das hat konkrete
folgen auch und gerade für deutschland
und seine armee bevor wir dazu reden
zeigt florian neumann eine
verteidigungsallianz die voll setzt auf
abschreckung und eindämmung
als die rednerpulte in madrid wieder
abgebaut sind die konzepte verstaut die
fahnen weggetragen bleibt zum beispiel
diese frage an kajak einers
premierministerin eines der frontstadt
für den norden
wenn sie jetzt zurück nach island reisen
fühlen sie sich auch besser geschützt
dass unsere sorgen wir bewegen uns von
abschreckung zu echter verteidigung das
bedeutet dann sind wir in der lage jeden
zentimeter des nato gebietes vom ersten
moment an zu verteidigen das ist ein
sehr wichtiges signal für meine
mitbürger
die estnische premier ministerin hat auf
dem gipfel erlebt wie die nato sich neu
ausrichtet zurück in den kalten krieg
das hält der nato-generalsekretär schon
fast für verharmlosend
leben in einer gefährlichere weniger
vorhersehbaren welt wir haben einen
heißen krieg mitten in europa
in dieser lage bekommt die nato wohl
bald verstärkung von leistungsfähigen
armeen aus schweden und finnland auf dem
gipfel rückt der nato beitritt der
beiden staaten einen entscheidenden
schritt näher auch wenn viele parlamente
auch das türkische den beitritt noch
ratifizieren müssen währenddessen
rätselt die weltöffentlichkeit was hat
der türkische präsident erdogan für
seine zustimmung bekommen joe biden sein
kollege aus den usa will von einem
tauschgeschäft nichts wissen aber
irgendwie zeitgleich stellt er der
türkei kampfflieger in aussicht
ich habe schon im dezember gesagt wir
sollten der türkei f 16 kampfjet
verkaufen und sie modernisieren es ist
nicht in unserem interesse das nicht zu
tun
derweil wirft der russische präsident
putin auch wegen dieser geplanten
erweiterung der nato heute neuen
imperialismus vor ein vorwurf den der
deutsche kanzler schaaf konnte
das ist ehrlicher weise ziemlich
lächerlich dann tatsächlich ist die nato
eine defensive allianz sie schreibt
keine anderen länder an tatsächlich ist
es putin der imperialismus zum ziel
seiner politik gemacht hat bei anderen
themen war ich drin auf scholz' lieber
aus keine antwort etwa auf die frage ob
ihr der lieferung von westlichen
kampfpanzern in die ukraine zustimmen
wird anders die estnische premier
ministerin sollte deutschland sie
liefern
deutschland muss entscheiden was es hat
und man kann aber aus ukrainischer sicht
ja für uns ist es wichtig dass die
ukraine die aggression zurückbringen
kann
die nato rückt zusammen im zeichen des
russischen kriegs gegen die ukraine aber
nicht so eng dass nicht doch noch platz
bliebe für manchen echten konflikt
ja da ändert sich enorm was ein bisschen
sprechen mit christoph heusgen erst
leiter der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
er war langjähriger außenpolitik berater
von bundeskanzlerin angela merkel heraus
keinen guten abend fantasie dass der
frieden ist zerschlagen russland als
unmittelbarste bedrohung so steht das
wörtlich im neuen strategiekonzept
wenn sie das lesen herausgehen was sagt
das über die welt in der wir jetzt leben
ja sie haben das ja in ihrem bericht
schon dargestellt indem sie james bond
und die alten zeiten wieder
wachgerufen haben wir sind in gewissem
sinne da wo wir nach dem ende des
zweiten weltkriegs war in einer
konfrontation mit seiner zeit der
sowjetunion heute heute mit russland und
die maßnahmen die wir jetzt ergreifend
sind maßnahmen die den vergleichbar sind
die wir im kalten krieg ergriffen haben
das heißt haus gehen wir sind im kalten
krieg nur das ja aktuell ein ganz heißer
krieg noch oben drauf kommt wenn sie uns
das mal einordnen ist das jetzt aktuell
aus ihrer sicht die gefährlichste
situation seit ende des zweiten
weltkriegs ist absolut die gefährlichste
situation insofern als
präsident putin mit seinen angriff auf
die ukraine einen zivilisationsbruch
begangen hat er hat ein land angegriffen
ohne irgendwelche völkerrechtliche
grundlage einfach aus willkür weil er
aus meiner sicht sehr viel auch zu
seiner stärkung seiner innenpolitischen
situation mit nationalistischem oder
eben imperialistischen gehabe stärke
demonstrieren will und darauf muss
beantwortet werden jetzt habe ich vorhin
aus dem strategiepapier der nato zitiert
so ein papier ist geduldig wie einig ist
denn die nato wirklich wann wird sich
das dann tatsächlich beweisen dann
dieser gipfel war schon ein
sehr wichtiger ich glaube schon ein
historischer gipfel denn die
entscheidungen die getroffen worden sind
sind schon ganz bedeutend die
erweiterung haben sie erwähnt aber dann
das strategische konzept wo klare
aussagen getroffen werden so worden sind
und dann vor allem die entscheidung
jetzt
300.000 truppen 300.000 soldaten
bereitzustellen
für eine schnelle eingreiftruppe das
sind schon dramatische entscheidungen
aber wir hören jetzt bei der nato wir
haben auch immer beim g7-gipfel der
gerade zu ende gegangen ist hinter den
kulissen gehört wir brauchen einen
langen atem haben die staaten den denn
haben die bürgerinnen und bürger den
denn wenn das gas knapp wird wenn die
preise weiter steigen und die wirtschaft
schlapp macht das ist die hauptfrage
putin denkt dass unsere gesellschaften
dekadente gesellschaften sind dass wir
das nicht durchhalten dass wir wenn
jetzt er hat ja den gashahn halb
abgedreht dass wir da nervös werden und
dann sagen werden nein nein jetzt drehen
wir bei jetzt machen wir nicht eine
solche harte politik das ist jetzt eine
kleine eine auslands des willens der
bereitschaft hier putin einhalt zu
gebieten und das müssen wir tun und das
ist in den letzten drei gipfeln doch
klar zum ausdruck gekommen dass wir da
zusammen stehen und dass wir putin nicht
die chance geben mit seinem
imperialistischen gehabe zu gewinnen im
kalten krieg gab es dieses legendäre
rote telefon haben wir jetzt noch
irgendeinen draht nach moskau eigentlich
es wird es hat auch im wie sie sagen im
kalten krieg solche drehte gegeben es
wird auch zwischen den militärs solche
drehte geben da wissen wir nicht
bescheid darüber aber das hat es in der
vergangenheit immer immer gegeben da
wird es sowas wird auch heute heute
existieren das klingt jetzt ein bisschen
nach hoffnung auf ihrer seite politisch
gibt es keinen kontakt oder
es wird ja immer wieder mal gibt es
kontakte das problem ist ja dass das
putin als partner eigentlich ausfällt er
fällt aus weil er in der vergangenheit
die zusagen die er gemacht hat die
verträge die er unterzeichnet hat die
vereinbarung die er getroffen hat er hat
ja nichts gehalten er hat keine
vereinbarung gehalten deswegen ist er
kein glaubwürdiger partner deswegen ist
ja jedes papier was man mit ihm
unterschreibt ist nicht das papier wert
auf das ist auch dass er seine
unterschrift setzt jetzt haben wir in
der vergangenheit auf wandel durch
annäherung gesetzt die gefahr viel zu
spät gesehen speziell auch
bundeskanzlerin merkel die sie beraten
haben herausgehen jetzt muss die
bundeswehr natürlich enorm aufholen das
gilt ja sowieso schon aber auch nochmal
für diese neuen nato aufgaben ich würde
gerne mal so einen kleinen
zahlenvergleich reinbringen die
bundeswehr hat bisher schon ein nato
gefechts verband in litauen geführt
anfangs mit 600 soldaten 600 jetzt will
deutschland eine division stellen das
sind 15.000 soldatinnen und soldaten ist
das überhaupt möglich dass die
bundeswehr ein glaubwürdiges
abschreckungspotenzial liefern kann
erstmal muss ich zu ihrer kleinen
unterstellung was sagen die
bundeskanzlerin hat in ihrer zeit alles
getan auch die die umsetzung des minsker
abkommens auf diplomatischem weg
weiterzukommen wirklich alles versucht
und putin hat es noch nicht ja es hat
mich glaube ich sollte nur sagen sie hat
das schon alles versucht um diplomatisch
weiterzukommen so mit dem minsk abkommen
und in den verhandlungen so putin hat
eben alles eingerissen und jetzt müssen
die konsequenzen getragen werden müssen
sie diese 600 soldaten da war
deutschland mit an vorderster front dass
wir das gemacht haben und es ist logisch
die eben hat die premierministerin aus
estland das gesagt dass das aufgestockt
wird dazu hat sich die bundesregierung
bekannt das heißt das jetzt in den
nächsten jahren bis 2025 bis die etwa
15.000 deutschen soldaten die dort
mitwirken sind wirklich so einsatzbereit
sind aber das ist wichtig und das muss
jetzt erfolgen und ich bin
zuversichtlich dass das auch erfolgen
wird sagt christoph heusgen leiter der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz haben
danke fürs gespräch gerne sie wird
unser nächstes thema hat natürlich auch
damit zu tun wie alles mit allem zu tun
hat in diesen zeiten die zahl der
arbeitslosen in deutschland ist
gestiegen im juni das liegt am
sogenannten ukraine effekt denn zum
ersten mal werden auch flüchtlinge von
dort in der statistik mit erfasst
idealerweise soll der arbeitsmarkt sie
aufnehmen und experten sagen es gebe
tatsächlich gute perspektiven was es
aber auch gibt immer noch sind viele
hürden peter böhme
lukas koller ist eine junge ärztin aus
odessa plastische chirurgie sechs jahre
berufserfahrung in der ukraine als der
krieg auch in ihr leben brach wurden
träume zerstört
ich habe er große pläne für meine
zukunft gehabt bis der 24
februar kam
ich hatte viele sprechstunden vereinbart
dienstreisen geplant und mit einem
einzigen tag ist das alles vorbei
es fühlt sich an wie jemand stil dir
dein leben
olga will ihre approbation anerkennen
lassen bei einem fördern netzwerk des
bundesarbeitsministeriums um die 16
monate dauert das sprach erwerbe
beglaubigungen fachprüfungen
eine hohe verantwortung
wenn man jetzt in anderen beruf hat
sagen mal wenn sie jetzt mit friseuren
wir wäre es natürlich weniger den
anerkennung ist nichts anderes als ein
vergleich das einfach sichergestellt
wird dass ein arzt oder eine ärztin aus
dem ausland die gleiche qualifikation
haben wie ein arzt oder ärztin hier in
deutschland die meisten geflüchteten
sind frauen darum sitzen ja oft ärzten
schwestern pflegekräfte hierzulande
dringend gesucht doch die bundesagentur
dämpfte heute auf ihrer monats
pressekonferenz erwartungen die menschen
aus der ukraine könnten das
fachkräfteproblem lösen nein das wird
uns nicht den fachkräftemangel lösen das
muss man nicht glauben
erstens wissen wir nicht wie viele
menschen bei uns bleiben wollen wenn die
nett wenn die ukraine als nationalstaat
erhalten bleibt
werden viele zurückgehen wollen weil die
ehemänner alle in der ukraine sind die
durften nicht ausreisen also
das was wir an fachkräften brauchen ist
viel mehr als das was wir aus der
ukraine schöpfen könnten unklar ist wie
viele menschen aus der ukraine überhaupt
in deutschland leben oder schon wieder
weg sind im zuge der flucht wurden etwa
870.000 personen im
ausländerzentralregister
registriert bei den agenturen und
jobcentern sind momentan aber nur
267.000 im erwerbsfähigen alter
eingetragen ältere menschen nicht
eingerechnet und kinder auch nicht über
140.000 werden hierzulande unterrichtet
lernen deutsch wie in der realschule
friedrichstadt in düsseldorf
es ist momentan mit händen und füßen ich
arbeite größtenteils mit der englischen
sprache und lass es dann von den kindern
die englisch können übersetzer wenig bei
die kriegen die deutsche aufgaben hin
allerdings wenn ich deshalb deutscher
kläre verstehen nicht was ich von denen
will deswegen arbeitet ganz oft mit den
schülern die englisch können für die
kinder ist es schwierig sicherheit ja
aber eine erstmal verlorene heimat
es ist schwer in emotionaler hinsicht es
wird langsam normal irgendwie schaffen
wir es schritt für schritt
schritt für schritt auch bei olgas
kölner momentan sieht sie ihre zukunft
mit ihrem kleinen sohn stefan in
deutschland
russland hat heute die britische
botschaft in moskau einbestellt um bei
ihr protest einzulegen
es geht um das was der britische
premierminister am dienstag bei uns in
dieser sendung gesagt hatte dass sein
zitat offen beleidigende kommentare für
die er sich entschuldigen solle sagt
russland boris johnson hatte in dem
heute journal gespräch gesagt der
russische militär einsatz sei ein
perfektes beispiel für toxische
männlichkeit und weiter wenn putin eine
frau wäre so hätte er nicht einen so
verrückten machohaften krieg vom zaun
gebrochen die reaktion heute zeigt wie
genau und wie dünnhäutig der mann im
kreml dann doch die westlichen
reaktionen verfolgt und welche ihn
offenbar besonders treffen
die lage im kriegsgebiet in der ukraine
jetzt von johanna und da blicken wir auf
die ukrainische schlangen insel denn
russland hat seine truppen von der
militärisch wichtigen insel abgezogen
der ukrainische präsidialamt chef
verbuchte dies als erfolg der
ukrainischen armee ganz anders klingt
dagegen moskau und sprach von einer
geste des guten willens um
getreideexporte wieder zu ermöglichen
russland hatte die kleine und
strategisch relevante insel im schwarzen
meer zu beginn des angriffskriegs
erobert
das ist ein schlag für die klimapolitik
der us-regierung der oberste gerichtshof
der usa hat die befugnisse der
us-umweltbehörde eingeschränkt bisher
hatte die grenzwerte für den co2 ausstoß
von kohlekraftwerken festgelegt doch
damit überschreite die behörde ihre
kompetenzen oder urteil benötigt sie
eine genehmigung durch den kongress dort
haben die demokraten allerdings keine
ausreichende mehrheit hintergrund der
entscheidung des obersten gerichts war
eine klage von kohleunternehmen
und wir bleiben beim us amerikanischen
supreme court denn erstmals in der
geschichte der usa gehört dem gericht
nun eine schwarze verfassungsrichterin
an hitachi braun jackson ist heute
offiziell in ihr amt eingeführt worden
der 51-jährige war viele jahre
bundesrichterin mit dem liberalen lager
zugeordnet und wurde von us-präsident
beiden für den posten nominiert an der
konservativen mehrheit des obersten
gerichts ändert sich dadurch nichts
trotz wieder steigender corona zahlen
und kritik von vielen seiten sind die
bürger tests für die meisten menschen in
deutschland seit heute nicht mehr
kostenlos ab sofort fällt eine
selbstbeteiligung von mindestens 3 euro
an gratis bleibt bleiben die abstriche
nur noch für bestimmte personen darunter
zum beispiel kinder bis 5 jahre
infizierte zur frei testung bestimmte
risikogruppen sowie besucher oder
beschäftigte in krankenhäusern und
pflegeeinrichtungen in
israel ist der weg frei für neuwahlen
das israelische parlament hat am
vormittag seine selbstauflösung
beschlossen am ersten november soll die
vorgezogene parlamentswahl stattfinden
es ist die fünfte in gut dreieinhalb
jahren ist eine neue regierung im amt
ist übernimmt der jetzige außenminister
rapid geschäftsführung den posten von
ministerpräsident wenn es das acht
parteien bündnis dass israel bisher
regierte hatte im april seine hauchdünne
mehrheit in der knesset verloren
die würde des menschen ist unantastbar
so steht es im grundgesetz ganz vorn
artikel 1 absatz 1 wenn der
bundesjustizminister an dieses zentrale
versprechen der verfassung erinnert
macht er damit klar welchen stellenwert
das gesetz aus seiner sicht hat dass die
ampel koalition heute vorgestellt hat
das neue
selbstbestimmung gesetz damit sollen
menschen in deutschland in zukunft ihren
vornamen und ihr geschlecht beim
standesamt leichter ändern können ein
simpler verwaltungsakt statt der
bisherigen regelung die von vielen
betroffenen als diskriminierend
empfunden wird und als entwürdigend
heike slansky wer bin ich wer will ich
sein männlich weiblich oder vielleicht
weder noch diese fragen fehlten felicia
roulette bereits mit fünf jahren
sie kamen als junge zur welt stammt aus
einer konservativen familie konnte mit
niemandem über ihre gefühle sprechen ich
habe keine erinnerungen an irgendeiner
situation in der ich mich als selber als
junge bezeichnet hätte ich habe nur sehr
schnell gespürt dass die erwartet welt
an mich hat die erwartung war er sich in
junge bin und was ich nie und dann war
von anfang an klar dass irgendwas
zumindest anders ist mit 17 zog sie vom
land nach berlin fand gleichgesinnte
entschied sich für eine
geschlechtsumwandlung laut
transsexuellengesetz sind nur für die
juristische namens und geschlechts
änderung zwei gutachten nötig hohe
kosten intime fragen eine erniedrigende
anhörung vom amtsgericht die ampel will
das nun ändern stellte eckpunkte für ein
neues sogenanntes
selbstbestimmung gesetz vor das das
verfahren erheblich erleichtern sollen
trans geschlechtliche menschen haben
nicht das geschlecht das eben bei der
geburt zugewiesen wurde viele
außenstehende verhöhnen das so dass
diese menschen zu einer besonders
wohlhabenden gruppe in unserer
gesellschaft gehören das ist keine
krankheit sondern es ist auch wenn es
nicht der statistische normalfall ist
trotzdem
ein stück normalität und deshalb wollen
wir mit diesen menschen respektvoll
umgeht künftig soll man sein geschlecht
und vornamen selbst festlegen können ab
14 jahren mit einwilligung der eltern
oder eines familiengerichts kritik kommt
von der union nach unserer auffassung
sollte es in jedem fall auch bei
erwachsenen eine ergebnisoffene beratung
geben es sollte auch erst nach mehreren
jahren und nicht jährlich möglich sein
der minderjährige schutz kommt uns viel
zu kurz und gerade auch im bereich des
sport ist und in vielen anderen
bereichen gibt es noch viele ungeklärte
fragen
selbstdiagnose trans der
kinderschutzbund ist dafür ebenso der
frauenrat einige jugendpsychiater jedoch
warnen im alter von vierzehn könne die
tragweite dieser tiefgreifenden
entscheidung häufig nicht abgeschätzt
werden die meisten jugendlichen das
lehrt ja einfach auch die
alltagserfahrung sind in diesem alter
noch mitten in ihrer identitätsfindung
das heißt wesentliche reifen schritte
sind noch gar nicht vollzogen wir müssen
kindern jugendlichen im alter von 14 ja
auch ansonsten nicht die den
entsprechenden weitblick zu wesentliche
entscheidungen zu treffen es ist nur die
buchstaben im ausweis absolut reversibel
es gibt kein grund für diese moralische
panik die aufkommen sie befürchtet dass
auf einmal horden von jugendlichen auf
einmal ihren namen ändern möchten das
recht auf selbstbestimmung und
gesellschaftliche teilhabe cities ihr
freut sich dass die hohen hürden weit
weg sein
bis zum jahresende soll das gesetz
durchs bundeskabinett sein und käme dann
in den bundestag
noch einmal nachrichten jetzt
seit mitte des monats nicht russland nun
weniger gas nach deutschland als
eigentlich zugesagt und das setzt die
energieversorger unter druck juniper
schlägt jetzt alarm und fordert als
erster gasversorger staatliche hilfe
valerie haller in frankfurt die
gespräche mit der bundesregierung laufen
bereits worum geht es genau also laut
juniper geht es unter anderem um
staatliche kreditgarantien
möglicherweise sogar haben eine
beteiligung des bundes am unternehmen ja
und das zeigt schon
wie brenzlig die lage ist hintergrund
seit juni liefert russland deutlich
weniger gas als zugesichert an juniper
naja und um seine kunden weiter mit den
vereinbarten mengen zu beliefern muss
juniper das gas jetzt teuer anderswo
einkaufen kann aber wegen bestehender
verträge den mehrpreis nicht an seine
kunden weitergeben das bringt juniper
nun in existenzielle not an der
frankfurter börse stürzt die aktie
deutlich unter druck auch die beiden
versorger rwe und eon juniper ist der
größte deutsche gasversorger und
beliefert mehrere hundert stadtwerke
insofern gefährdet junipers schieflage
die gesamte gasversorgung befürchtet
wird auch eine kettenreaktion
denn die energiepreise steigen weiter
selbst gesunde unternehmen könnten bald
beim gaseinkauf in schwierigkeiten
geraten was könnte das dann letztendlich
für die an verbraucher halten deutlich
höhere kosten für strom und das heizen
zwar hat die bundesregierung die
alarmstufe für die gasversorgung
ausgerufen bisher aber dürfen versorger
diese drastisch gestiegenen preise nicht
auf die kunden abwälzen
sollte die regierung dafür grünes licht
geben könnte gas ganz schnell deutlich
teurer werden und nicht erst mit der
jahresendabrechnung danke galerien nach
frankfurt
der hanns-joachim-friedrichs-preis geht
dieses jahr an den spiegel reporter
christoph reuter und in
russischsprachigen fernsehsender ost
west tv aus berlin beide erhalten die
auszeichnung für ihre ukraine
berichterstattung ebenfalls freuen darf
sich die zdf kindernachrichtensendung
logo
sie wurde mit dem sonderpreis
ausgezeichnet
laut jury weil sie die komplizierte welt
lage klar und unaufgeregt erkläre
und es gibt eine aktuelle
unwetterwarnung des deutschen
wetterdienstes vor starken teils
schweren gewittern in teilen von bayern
baden württemberg und niedersachsen
und jetzt zur schwimm-wm in budapest da
hat lea bei heute über 25 kilometer im
freiwasser denkbar knapp die
goldmedaille verpasst nach fast
fünfeinhalb stunden schwimmen war sie
nur zwei zehntelsekunden langsamer als
die brasilianerin ana
am ende hieß es also silber für lemgo
damit können sich die deutschen
schwimmer zum abschluss der wm über
insgesamt neun medaillen freuen
wir hüten hier einen schatz beim zdf auf
dem lerchenberg in mainz ist von außen
nicht so einfach zu erkennen zwischen
autobahn und kreisrunder 70er jahre
architektur aber er ist da und wir
wissen um unser programm archiv also
sowas wie das filmische gedächtnis des
zdf ist jetzt komplett digitalisiert und
damit vor dem verfall gerettet
das kann sich jeder vorstellen der mal
eine videokassette beim altern zugesehen
hat von den sensiblen jahrzehnte alten
mats bändern gar nicht zu reden die
schätze aus dem archiv sind damit jetzt
aber auch viel einfacher abzurufen für
uns und für sie wie claudio armbruster
zeigt
meine damen und herren wir begrüßen sie
herzlich zum heutigen programm zu beginn
der heutigen sende folge bringen wird
nachrichten
das zdf in den sechzigern und da gibt es
schätze im archiv die nicht verloren
gehen sollten
doch die archive des zdf sind groß fast
sieben jahre hat es gedauert die alten
bänder digital zu sichern rund 400.000
bender rund 300.000 stunden fernsehen
und die wertvollen stunden kommen nun
nach und nach in die mediathek
besonders wertvoll die reihe zur person
von 1963 bis 66 traf der journalist und
spätere diplomat günter gaus
außergewöhnliche menschen zu
ausführlichen gesprächen unter einer
stunde macht er jetzt nicht heute sind
das zeitzeugnisse
herr bürgermeister brandt worin sehen
sie selbst ihre schwächen ihre möglichen
schwächen als politiker sie können
natürlich sagen sie sehen keine
darf ich mal hier etwas zum stil sagen
eines
mannes der politische verantwortung
trägt jeder muss wohl seinen eigenen
haben
zu meinem gehört dazu
dass dort wo ich
den vorsitz habe selten abgestimmt wird
frau hannah arendt sie sind die erste
frau die in dieser reihe porträtiert
werden soll in diesem herbst frau arendt
ist in der bundesrepublik ein buch über
den eichmann-prozess in jerusalem
erschienen und diese arbeit ist seit
ihrem erscheinen in amerika sehr sehr
heftig diskutiert worden die leute
nehmen mir eine sache
und das kann ich gewissermaßen für
stehen von außen nämlich dass ich dann
noch lachen kann und
ich war wirklich der meinung dass der
eichmann ein hanswurst und ich sage
ihnen ich habe dieses polizei verhört
3600 seiten gelesen und sehr genau
gelesen und ich weiß nicht wie oft ich
gelacht dabei mein land
nun dieser reaktion neben mir die leute
dagegen kann ich nichts machen ich weiß
aber eine sache
ich würde wahrscheinlich noch drei
minuten vor dem sicheren tod
ich freue mich dass wir jetzt 60 jahre
zdf programm nachhaltig und digital
sichern konnten darin sind große schätze
enthalten programm schätze aber auch
zeit historisch bedeutsame dokumente
diese sich anzuschauen wie zb die
ausleihe erleichtert auch gegenwart
besser verstehen zu koennen
manches ist nicht nur intellektuell
tiefgründig sondern auch einfach lustig
günter grass mit 38 darum tragen sie
einen schnurrbart
das hängt bei mir wahrscheinlich damit
zusammen weil wir
die unteren zehn vorstehen
ein schnurrbart gegen den unter bis an
diesen gesprächen kann man hängen
bleiben stundenlang aber irgendwann ist
eben schlafenszeit
23 uhr ist das programm des zweiten
deutschen fernsehens bmw
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja das ist heute anders überhaupt wird
heute auch deutlich weniger geraucht
hier bei uns der nato-generalsekretär
und damit machen wir den bogen zum
beginn dieser sendung ist gleich zu gast
bei maybrit illner krisengipfel gegen
putin wie lange hält der westen durch
eine spannende runde gleich hier im zdf
von uns allen beim heute-journal bis
morgen und noch der hinweis auf unser
heute-journal update gegen 0.30 mit
nacktem ihr dort dann auch ein
ausführliches interview mit estlands
ministerpräsidentin colours es angenehm
haben
[Musik]
guten abend zwar sind die großen
waldbrände der letzten tage in sachsen
und brandenburg unter kontrolle die
waldbrandgefahr ist aber vor allem
zwischen hamburg und berlin noch auf der
höchsten warnstufe
nadelwälder besonders die kiefernwälder
im norden und osten deutschlands sind
gefährdet hier ist der boden sandig und
feuchtigkeit versichert sofort hinzu
kommt sie haben kein dichtes blätterdach
es kommt mehr sonnenlicht durch dadurch
trocknen die nadeln und das gras auf dem
waldboden schnell aus gerät dieses
trockene gemisch in brand etwa durch
eine weggeworfene zigarette breiten sich
die flammen rasant aus
jetzt kommt aber und zwar in form einer
kaltfront aus dem westen des landes
durch diese calw und treibt aktuell
schwere gewitter vor sich her besonders
heftig war diese zelle im allgäu heute
nachmittag mit großem hagel auch der
ostalbkreis bekam einiges ab und dann
hat sich über dem ruhrgebiet noch eine
gewitterfront formiert die jetzt das
emsland erreicht hat in diesen gewittern
kann starker regen hinunter 66 liter pro
quadratmeter in oberstdorf 34 in
duisburg 29 in schwäbisch gmünd und das
meist in kurzer zeit es gab
überflutungen umgestürzte bäume züge
fielen aus auch telefonverbindungen und
kleinere erdrutsche waren auch dabei und
heute nacht kommt die front voran bis zu
einer linie nordsee bayerischer wald
lokal ist starkregen noch im südwesten
des landes möglich vor der front wird
die nacht sehr mild mit 16 bis 19 grad
hinten dran spüren wir aber schon eine
abkühlung mit nur 11 bis 15 grad und
morgen gibt es dann für alle einen
ordentlichen temperatursturz auf ein um
die 20 grad unter dem regen der front
ist es sogar teils noch weniger nur ganz
im osten habe noch schwüle 28 grad hier
verlagert sich auch die
gewittertätigkeit im tagesverlauf in
lokal mit unwetter von westen her setzt
allerdings eine wetterberuhigung 1 doch
dazwischen da gibt es auch mal lang
anhaltenden regen doch schon am
wochenende ist es wieder durchweg
trocken und mit bis 30 grad steht uns
ein waschechtes sommer wochenende bevor
das war von uns tschüss